but I also want to again take this
opportunity to thank the Senators for
their long and considerable attention
over the course of the last two days I'm
not sure the Chief Justice is fully
aware of just how rare it is how
extraordinary it is for the House
members to be able to command the
attention of senators sitting silently
for hours or even for minutes for that
matter of course it doesn't hurt that
the morning starts out every day with
the sergeant at arms warning you that if
you don't you will be imprisoned it's
our hope that when the trial concludes
and you've heard us and you've heard the
president's counsel over a series of
long days that you don't choose
imprisonment instead of anything further
two days ago we made the case for
documents and for witnesses in the trial
yesterday we walked through the
chronology the factual chronology at
some length today we'll go through
article 1 the constitutional
underpinnings of abuse of power and
apply the facts of the present scheme to
the law and constitution and here I must
ask you for some forbearance of
necessity there will be some repetition
of information from yesterday's
chronology and I want to explain the
reason for it you've now heard hundreds
of hours of deposition and live
testimony from the House condensed into
an abbreviated narrative of the facts we
will now show you these facts and many
others and how they are interwoven you
will see some of these facts and videos
therefore in a new context in a new
light in the light of what else we know
and why it compels a finding of guilt
and conviction so there is some method
to our madness
tomorrow we will conclude the
presentation of the facts in law on
article 1 and we will begin and complete
the same on article 2 the president's
unconstitutional obstruction of Congress
the President's Council will then have
three days to make their presentations
and then you will have 16
hours to ask questions and then the
trial will begin and then you will
actually get to hear from the witnesses
yourself and then you'll get to see the
documents yourself or so we hope and so
do the American people and after their
testimony and after we've had closing
arguments then it will be in your hands
so let's begin today's presentation and
I yield to house manager Nadler good
morning mr. chief justice
senators my fellow house managers and
counsel for the president this is the
third day of a solemn occasion for the
American people the articles of
impeachment against President Trump
ranked among the most serious charges
ever brought against the president and
as our recital of the facts indicated
the articles are overwhelmingly
supported by the evidence amassed by the
house notwithstanding the president's
complete stonewalling his attempt to
block all witnesses and all documents
from the United States Congress the
first article of impeachment charges the
president with abuse of power President
Trump used the powers of his office to
solicit a foreign nation to interfere in
our elections for his own personal
benefit note that the act of
solicitation itself just the ask
constitutes an abuse of power but
President Trump went further in order to
secure his favor from Ukraine he
withheld two official acts of immense
value first he withheld the release of
391 million dollars in vital military
assistance appropriated by Congress and
a bipartisan basis which Ukraine needed
to fight Russian aggression and second
president Trump withheld a long
sought-after White House meeting which
would confirm
to the world that America stands behind
Ukraine in its ongoing struggle the
president's conduct is wrong it is
illegal it is dangerous and it captures
the worst fears of our found frame of
our founders and the framers of the
Constitution since President George
Washington took office in 1789 no
president has abused his power in this
way let me say that again no president
has ever used his office to compel a
foreign nation to help him cheat in our
elections prior presidents would be
shocked to the core by such conduct and
rightly so now because President Trump
has largely failed to convince the
country that his conduct was remotely
acceptable he has adopted a fallback
position he argues that even if we
disapprove of his misconduct we cannot
remove him for it frankly that argument
is itself terrifying it confirms that
this president sees no limits on his
power or on his ability to use his
public office for private gain and of
course the president also believes that
he can use his power to cover up his
crimes that leads me to the second
article of impeachment which charges
that the president categorically
indiscriminately and unlawfully
obstructed our inquiry the congressional
inquiry into his conduct this
presidential stonewalling of Congress is
unprecedented in the 238 year history of
our constitutional republic it puts even
President Nixon to shame
taken together the articles and the
evidence conclusively established the
president Trump has placed his own
personal political interests first he
has placed them above our national
security above our free and fair
elections and above our system of checks
and balances this conduct is not America
first
it is Donald Trump first Donald Trump
swore an oath to faithfully execute the
laws that means putting the nation's
interests above his own and the
president has repeatedly flagrantly
violated his oath and I just want to
stress that if this what we're if what
we're talking about is not impeachable
then nothing is impeachable this is
precisely the misconduct that the
framers created a constitution including
impeachment to protect against all of
the legal experts testify testified
before the House Judiciary Committee
those invited by the Democrats and those
invited by the Republicans all agreed
that the conduct we have charged
constitutes high crimes and misdemeanors
professor Michael Gerhart the author of
six books and the only joint witness
when the house considered President
Clinton's case put it simply if what
we're talking about is not impeach Abel
then nothing is impeach Abel Professor
Jonathan Turley called by the
Republicans as a witness agreed that the
articles charge an offense that is
impeachable in his written testimony he
stated the use of military aid for a
quid pro quo to investigate one's
political opponent if proven can be an
impeachable offense close quote
thus far we have presented the core
factual narrative none of that record
can be seriously disputed and none of it
will be disputed we can predict what the
president's lawyers will say in the next
few days I urge you senators to listen
to it carefully you will hear
accusations and name-calling you will
hear a complaints about the process in
the house and the motives of the
managers you will hear that this all
comes down to a phone call that was
perfect as if you had not just seen
evidence of a months-long
government-wide effort to extort a
foreign government but you will not hear
a refutation of the evidence you will
not hear testimony to refute the
testimony you have seen indeed if the
President had any exculpate ory
witnesses even a single one he would be
demanding their appearance here instead
of urging you not to permit additional
witnesses to testify so now let me offer
a preview of the path ahead first we
will examine the law of impeachable
offenses with a focus on abuse of power
that will be the subject of my
presentation then my colleagues will
apply the law to the facts they will
demonstrate that the president has
unquestionably committed the high crimes
and misdemeanors outlined in the first
article of impeachment once those
presentations are concluded we will take
the same approach to demonstrating
president Trump's obstruction of
Congress the second article of
impeachment we will begin by stating the
law then we will review the facts and
then we will apply the law to the facts
proving that President Trump is guilty
on the second article of impeachment as
well with that roadmap to guide us I
will begin by walking through the law of
abuse of power here I'll start by
defining the phrase in the Constitution
high crimes and misdemeanors when the
framers selected this term they meant it
to capture as George Mason put it all
manner of great and dangerous offenses
against the nation and in contemporary
terms the framers had three specific
offenses in mind abuse of power betrayal
of the nation through foreign
entanglements and corruption of
elections you can think of these as the
ABCs of high crimes and misdemeanors
abuse betrayal and corruption the
framers believed that any one of these
standing alone justified removal from
office
professor Noah Feldman of Harvard Law
School explained this well before the
House Judiciary Committee here is his
explanation of why the framers created
the impeachment power
the framers provided for the impeachment
of the president because they feared
that the president might abuse the power
of his office for personal benefit to
corrupt the electoral process and ensure
his re-election or to subvert the
national security of the United States
that is the standard as described by
Professor Feldman
it is correct and of course we're all
three of these concerns appear at once
abuse betrayal and corruption that is
where we have the strongest possible
case for removing a president from
office later on we will apply this rule
to the facts abuse we will show that
President Trump abused his power when he
used his office to solicit and pressure
Ukraine to meddle in our elections for
his personal gain betrayal we will show
that he betrayed that vital national
interests specifically our national
security by withholding diplomatic
support and military aid from Ukraine
even as it faced armed Russian
aggression corruption president Trump's
intent was to corrupt our elections to
his personal political benefit he put
his personal interest in retaining power
above free and fair elections and above
the principle that Americans must govern
themselves without interference from
abroad article 1 thus charges a high
crime and misdemeanor that blends abuse
of power betrayal of the nation and
corruption in elections into a single
unforgivable scheme that is why this
president must be removed from office
especially before he continues his
effort to corrupt our next election the
charges set forth in the first article
of impeachment are firmly grounded in
the Constitution of the United States
simply stated impeachment is the
Constitution's final answer to a
president who mistakes himself for a
king the framers had risked their
freedom and their lives to escape
monarchy together they resolved to build
a nation committed to democracy and the
rule of law a beacon to the world in an
age of our
stock receipt in the United States of
America we the people would be sovereign
we would choose our leaders and hold
them accountable for how they exercise
power in our behalf in writing our
constitution the framers recognized that
we needed a chief executive who could
lead the nation with efficiency energy
and dispatch so they created a powerful
presidency invested it with immense
public trust but this solution created a
different problem the framers were not
naive
they knew that power corrupts they knew
that Republic's cannot flourish and that
people cannot live free under a corrupt
leader they foresaw that a president
faithful only to himself would endanger
every American so the framers built
guardrails to ensure that the American
people would remain free and to ensure
that out-of-control presidents would not
destroy everything that they sought to
build they imposed elections every four
years to ensure accountability they
banned the president from profiting off
his office they divided the powers of
the federal government across three
branches and they required the President
to swear an oath to faithfully execute
the laws to the framers the concept of
faithful execution was profoundly
important it prohibited the president
from exercising power in bad faith or
with corrupt intent and thus ensured
that the president would put the
American people first not himself a few
framers would have stopped there this
minority feared vesting any branch of
government with the power to remove a
president from office they would have
relied on elections alone to address
rogue presidents but that view was was
decisively rejected at the
Constitutional Convention convening in
the shadow of rebellion and revolution
the framers would not deny the nation
and escape from presidents who deemed
themselves above the law instead they
adopted the power of impeachment in so
doing they offered a clear answer to
George Mason's question shall any man be
above justice as Mason himself explained
some mode of displacing an unfit
magistrate is rendered indispensable by
the fal ability of those who choose as
well as by the corrupt corrupt ability
of the man chosen unlike in in Britain
the president would answer personally to
Congress and thus to the nation for any
serious wrongdoing but this decision
raised the question what conduct would
justify impeachment and removal as
careful students of history the framers
knew that threats to democracy can take
many forms they feared would be monarchs
but also warned against fake populist
charismatic demagogues and corrupt
kleptocrats in describing the kind of
leader who might Menace the nation
Alexander Hamilton offered an especially
striking portrait mr. Schiff read this
portrait in his introductory remarks and
it bears repetition when a man
unprincipled in private life desperate
in his fortune bold in his temper known
to have scoffed and private at the
principles of Liberty when such a man is
seen to mount the hobbyhorse of
popularity to join in the cry of danger
to Liberty to take every opportunity of
embarrassing the general government and
bringing it under suspicion to flatter
and fall in with all the nonsense of the
zealots of the day it may justly be
suspected that his object is to throw
things into confusion that he may ride
the storm and direct the whirlwind
Hamilton was a wise man he foresaw
dangerous far ahead of his time given
the many threats they had to anticipate
the frame is considered extremely broad
grounds for moving presidents for
example they debated setting the bar at
maladministration to allow removal for
run-of-the-mill policy disagreements
between Congress and the president they
also considered very narrow grounds
strictly limiting impeachment to treason
and bribery ultimately they struck a
balance they did not want presidents
removed for ordinary political or policy
to
agreements but the intended impeachment
to reach the full spectrum of
presidential misconduct that might
threaten the Constitution and they
intended our Constitution to endure for
the ages so they adopted a standard
meant as Mason put it to capture all
manner of great and dangerous offenses
incompatible with the Constitution
this standard borrowed from the British
Parliament was high crimes and
misdemeanors in England the standard was
understood to capture offences against
the constitutional system itself that is
confirmed by the use of the word high as
well as by parliamentary practice from
1376 to 1787 the House of Commons and
peached officials on a few general
grounds mainly consisting of abuse of
power betrayal of national security and
foreign policy corruption treason
bribery and disregarding the powers of
Parliament the phrase high crimes and
misdemeanors
thus covered offences against the nation
itself in other words crimes against the
British constitution as scholars were
shown the same understanding prevailed
on this side of the Atlantic in the
colonial period and under newly ratified
state constitutions most impeachment
targeted abuse of power betrayal of the
revolutionary cause corruption treason
and bribery these experiences were well
known to the framers of the Constitution
history thus teaches that high crimes
and misdemeanors referred mainly to acts
committed by officials using their power
of privileges that inflicted grave harm
on society such great and dangerous
offenses included treason bribery abuse
of power betrayal of the nation and
corruption of office and they were
unified by a clear theme officials who
abused abandoned or sought to benefit
personally from their public trust and
who threatened the rule of law if left
in power faced impeachment and removal
abuse betrayal corruption
this is exactly the understanding that
the framers incorporated into the
Constitution as Supreme Court Justice
Robert Jackson wisely observed the
purpose of the Constitution was not only
to grant power but to keep it from
getting out of hand
Noah is that truer than in the
presidency as the framers created the
formidable chief executive they made
clear that impeachment is justified for
serious abuse of power
James Madison stated that impeachment is
necessary because the president quote
might pervert his administration into a
scheme of oppression close quote
Hamilton set the standard for removal at
an abuse or violation of some public
trust and in Massachusetts Reverend
Samuel Stillman asked was such a
prospect of impeachment who will dare to
abuse the powers vested in him by the
people
time and again Americans who wrote and
ratified the Constitution confirmed that
presidents may be impeached for abusing
the power entrusted to them to the
framing generation moreover abuse of
power was a well understood offense it
took two basic forms the first occurred
when someone exercise power in ways far
beyond what the law allowed or in ways
that destroyed checks on their own
authority the second occurred when an
official exercised power to obtain an
improper personal benefit while ignoring
or injuring the national interest in
other words the president may commit an
impeachable abuse of power in two
different ways by engaging and clearly
forbidden acts or by taking actions that
are allowed but for reasons that are not
allowed for instance to obtain corrupted
private benefits let me unpack that idea
starting with the first category conduct
clearly inconsistent with the law
including the law of checks and balances
the generation that rebelled against
George the third knew what absolute
power looked like it was no abstraction
to them they had a different idea in
mind when they organized our governor
most significantly they placed the
president under the law not above it
that means the president may exercise
only the powers vested in him by the
Constitution he must also respect the
legal limits on the exercise of those
powers a president who egregiously
refuses to follow these restrictions by
engaging in wrongful conduct may be
subject to impeachment for abuse of
power to American impeachment inquiries
have involved claims that a president
grossly violated the Constitution's
separation of powers the first was in
1868 when the house impeach President
Andrew Johnson who had succeeded Abraham
Lincoln after his assassination at
Ford's Theatre in firing the Secretary
of War President Johnson allegedly
violated the tenure of office Act which
restricted the president's power to
remove cabinet members during the term
of the president who would have pointed
them the House of Representatives
approved the articles charging him with
conduct forbidden by law that is an
action that is an abuse of power on its
face ultimately the Senate acquitted
President Johnson by one vote this was
partly because there was a strong
argument that the tenure of office Act
which President Johnson was charged with
violating was itself unconstitutional a
position the Supreme Court later
accepted of course historians have also
noted that a key senator appears to have
changed his vote at the last minute in
exchange for promises of special
treatment by President Johnson so
perhaps that acquittal meets means a
little less than meets the eye
in any event just over a hundred years
later the House Judiciary Committee
accused the second chief executive of
abusing his power in a manner
egregiously inconsistent with the law
now the committee charged President
Nixon with obstruction of Congress based
on his merit 'less assertion of
executive privilege to cover-up key
White House tape recordings we will have
more to say about the obstruction charge
in a moment but the Nixon case also
exemplifies the second way a president
can abuse his power
President Nixon faced
two more articles of impeachment both of
these articles charged him with abusing
the powers of his office with corrupt
intent one focused on his abuse of power
to obstruct law enforcement the other
targeted his abuse of power to target
political opponents each article
enumerated specific abuses by President
Nixon many of which involved the
wrongful corrupt exercise of
presidential power and many of which
were likely not statutory crimes in
explaining its second article the House
Judiciary Committee stated that
President Nixon's conduct was undertaken
for his personal political advantage and
not in furtherance of any valid national
policy objection objective that should
sound familiar to everyone here it
reflects the stand that I've already
articulated the exercise of official
power to corruptly obtain a personal
benefit while ignoring or injuring the
national interest to be sure all
presidents account to some extent for
how the decisions in office may affect
their political prospects the
Constitution does not forbid that
elected officials can and should care
about how voters will react to their
decisions they will often care about
whether their decisions make it more
likely that they will be reelected but
there is a difference a difference that
matters between political calculus and
outright corruption some uses of
presidential power are so outrageous
so obviously improper than if they are
undertaken for a president's own
personal gain with injury or
indifference to core national interests
than they are obviously high crimes and
misdemeanors otherwise even the most
egregious wrongdoing can be could be
justified as disagreement over policy or
politics and corruption that would have
shocked the framers that they expressly
sought to prohibit would overcome the
protections they established for our
benefit and there should be nothing
surprising about impeaching a president
for using his power with corrupt motives
the House and Senate have confirmed at
this point in Prior impeachment
more important the Constitution itself
says that we can do so to start the
Constitution requires that the president
faithfully execute the law a president
who acts with corrupt motives putting
himself above country has acted
faithless Li not faithfully executed the
laws
moreover the two impeachable offenses
that the Constitution enumerates treason
and bribery each require proof of the
president's mental state for treason
he must have acted with a disloyal mind
according to the Supreme Court and that
is well established that the elements of
bribery include corrupt motives and some
to the framers it was dangerous for
officials to exceed their constitutional
power but it was equally dangerous
perhaps more so for officials to use
their power with corrupt nefarious
motives
thus perverting public trust for public
or private gain abuse of power is
clearly an impeachable offense under the
Constitution to be honest this should
not be a controversial statement I find
it amazing that the president rejects it
yet he does he insists that there is no
such thing as impeachable abuse of power
this position is dead wrong all prior
impeachments considered considered of
high office have always included abuse
of power all of the experts who
testified before the House Judiciary
Committee including those called by the
Republicans agreed that abuse of power
is a high crime and misdemeanor here is
testimony from Professor Pam Carlin of
Stanford Law School joined by Professor
Gerhard du scholars of impeachment
generally agree that abuse of power is
an impeachable offense yes they do
professor Gerhart do you agree that
abuse of power is impeachable yes sir
professor Turley who testified at
Republican invitation
that view in fact he not only agreed but
he quotes stressed that it is possible
to establish a case for impeachment
based on a non criminal allegation of
abuse of power
professor Turley is hardly the only
legal expert to take that view another
who comes to mind is Professor Alan
Dershowitz at least Alan Dershowitz in
1998 back then here is what he had and
what he had to say about impeachment for
abuse of power because it certainly
doesn't have to be a crime if you have
somebody who completely corrupts the
office of president and who abuses
trusts and who poses great danger to our
Liberty you don't need a technical crime
but we need not look to 1998 to find one
of president Trump's key allies
espousing this view consider the
comments of our current Attorney General
William Barr a man known for his
extraordinarily expansive view of
executive power in Attorney General's
view in attorney general bars view has
expressed about 18 months ago presidents
cannot be indicted or criminally
investigated but that's okay because
they can can be impeached
that's the safeguard and then an
impeachment Attorney General bar added
the president is answerable for any
abuses of discretion and may be held
accountable under law for his misdeeds
in office in other words Attorney
General bar who believes along with the
Office of Legal Counsel that a president
may not be indicted believes that that's
okay we don't need that safeguard
against a president who would commit
abuses of power it's okay because he can
be impeached
that's the safeguard for abuses of
discretion and for his misdeeds in
office more recently a group of the
nation's leading constitutional scholars
ranging across the ideological spectrum
from Harvard Law Professor Larry tried
to former Ronald Reagan Solicitor
General Charles freed issued a statement
affirming that quote abuse of power
counts as an instance of impeachable
high crimes and misdemeanors under the
Constitution they added that was clearly
the view of the Constitution's framers I
could go on but you get the point
everyone except President Trump and his
lawyers agree that president that
presidents can be a Peete impeached for
abuse of power the president's position
amounts to nothing but self-serving
constitutional nonsense and it is
dangerous nonsense at that a president
who sees no limit on his power
manifestly threatens the Republic the
Constitution always matches power with
constraint that is true even if powers
vested in the chief executives nobody is
entitled to wield power under the
Constitution if they ignore them or
betray the nation's interests to advance
their own President Nixon was wrong in
asserting that quote when the President
does it that means it is not illegal and
President Trump was equally wrong when
he declared that he had the power the
right to do whatever I want as president
under the Constitution he is subject to
impeachment and removal for abuse of
power and as we will prove that is
exactly what must happen here of course
president Trump's abuse of power as
charged in the first article of
impeachment and supported by a mountain
of evidence is aggravated by another
concern at the heart of the
Constitution's impeachment Clause
betrayal the founders of our country
were not fearful men when they wrote our
Constitution they had only recently won
a bloody war for independence but as
they looked outward from their new
nation they saw Kings scheming for power
promising fabulous wealth to spies and
deserters the United States could be in
mention in such conspiracies former
foreign powers warned Elbridge Gerry
we'll inter meddle in our affairs and
spare no expense to influence them the
young Republic might not survive a
president who schemed with other nations
entangling himself in secret deals that
harmed our democracy that reality loomed
over the impeachment debate in
Philadelphia explaining why the
Constitution required an impeachment
option Madison argued that the president
might betray his trust to foreign powers
to be sure the framers did not intend
impeachment for genuine good-faith
disagreements between the President and
Congress over matters of diplomacy but
they were explicit that betrayal of the
nation through plots with foreign powers
must result in removal from office and
no such betrayal scared them more than
foreign interference in our democracy in
his farewell address George Washington
warned Americans quote to be constantly
awake since history and experience prove
that foreign influence is one of the
most painful foes of republican
government close quote and the no letter
to Thomas Jefferson John Adams wrote you
are apprehensive of foreign interference
foreign intrigue influence so am i but
as often as elections happen the danger
of foreign influence recurs the framers
never suggested that the president's
role in foreign affairs should prevent
Congress from impeaching him for
treachery in his dealings case in point
they wrote a constitution that gives
Congress extensive responsibility over
Foreign Affairs Congress including the
power to declare war regulate foreign
commerce establish uniform rule of
naturalization and to find offenses
against the law of nations contrary to
the claims you heard the other day that
the president has plenary authority in
foreign affairs and there is nothing
Congress can do about it the Supreme
Court has stated that constitutional
authority over the conduct of the
Foreign Relations of our government is
shared between the executive and
legislative branches or to quote another
Supreme Court case
the executive is not free from the
ordinary controls and checks of Congress
merely because Foreign Affairs are at
issue in these realms justice Jackson
wrote the Constitution enjoins upon its
branches separateness
but interdependence autonomy but
reciprocity where the president betrays
our national security and foreign policy
interests for his own personal gain
he's unquestionably subject to
impeachment and removal the same is true
of a different concern raised by the
framers the use of presidential power to
corrupt the elections and the office of
the presidency the framers were no
strangers to corruption they understood
that corruption had broke in Rome too
based Britain and threatened America
they saw no shortage of threats to the
Republic and fought valiantly to guard
against them but as one scholar writes
the big fear underlying all the small
fears was whether they'd be able to
control corruption so the framers
attempted to build a government in which
officials would not use public power for
personal benefits disregarding the
public good in pursuit of their own
advancement this principle applied with
special force to the presidency as men
as Madison emphasized because the
presidency was to be administered by a
single man his corruption might be fatal
to the Republic indeed no fewer than
four delegates to the Constitutional
Convention
Madison plus Morris Mason and Randolph
listed corruption as a central reason
why presidents must be subject to
impeachment and removal from office
impeachment was seen as especially
necessary for presidential conduct
corrupting our system of political
self-government the framers foresaw and
feared that a president might someday
place his personal interest in
reelection above our abiding commitment
to democracy such a president and their
view would need to be removed from
office professor Feldman made this point
in his testimony before the house
Judiciary Committee the framers reserved
impeachment for situations where the
president abused his office that is used
it for his personal advantage and in
particular they were specifically
worried about a situation where the
president used his office to facilitate
corruptly his own re-election that's in
fact why they thought they needed
impeachment and why waiting for the next
election wasn't good enough
professor Feldman's testimony is
grounded in the records of the
Constitutional Convention there William
Davey warned that a president who abuses
office might spare no efforts or means
whatever to get himself reelected and
thus to escape justice
George Mason built on Davey's position
asking shall the man who has practice
corruption and by that means procured
his appointment in the first instance he
suffered to escape punishment by
repeating his guilt
Mason's concern was straightforward he
feared that presidents would win
election by improperly influencing
members of the electoral college
governor Morris later occurred later
echoed this point urging that the
executive or therefore to be impeachable
for corrupting his electors taken
together these debates demonstrate an
essential point the framers knew that a
president who abused power to manipulate
elections presented the greatest
possible threat to the Constitution
after all the beating heart of the
famous project was a commitment to
popular sovereignty at a time when
democratic self-government existed
almost nowhere on earth the framers
imagined a society were powered where
power flowed from and returned to the
people that is why the president and
members of Congress must stand before
the public for re-election on fixed
terms and if a president abuses his
power to corrupt those elections he
threatens the entire system as Professor
Carlin explained in her testimony
drawing a foreign government into our
elections isn't a special
a serious abuse of power because it
undermines democracy itself our
Constitution begins with the words we
the people for a reason our government
in James Madison's words derives all its
powers directly or indirectly from the
great body of the people and the way it
derives these powers is through
elections elections matter both till the
legitimacy of our government and to all
of our individual freedoms because as
the Supreme Court declared more than a
century ago
voting is preservative of all rights
Professor Carlin is right elections
matter they make our government
legitimate and they protect our freedom
a president who abuses his power in
order to kneecap a political opponents
and spread Russian conspiracy theories a
president who uses his office to ask for
or even worse to compel foreign nations
to meddle in our elections is a
president who attacks the very
foundation of our Liberty that is a
grave abuse of power it is an
unprecedented betrayal of the national
interest it is a shocking corruption of
the election process and it is without
doubt a crime against the Constitution
warranting demanding removal from office
the framers expected that free elections
would use would be the usual means of
protecting our freedoms but they knew
that a president who sought foreign
assistance in his campaign must be
removed from office before he could
steal the next election in a last-ditch
legal defense of their client the
president's lawyers argue that
impeachment and removal are subject to
statutory crimes or to offenses against
established law that the president
cannot be impeached because he has not
committed a crime this view is
completely wrong it has no supporting
constitutional text and structure
original meeting congressional
precedents common sense or the consensus
of
experts in other words it conflicts with
every relevant consideration
professor gerhard succesfully succinctly
captured the consensus view in his
testimony
professor gerhard does a high crime and
misdemeanor require an actual statutory
crime no there Malayan does not
everything we know about the history of
impeachment reinforces the conclusion
that impeachable offenses do not have to
be crimes and again not all crimes are
impeachable offenses we look at again at
the context and gravity of the
misconduct this position was echoed by
the Republicans expert witness professor
Turley in his written testimony there he
stated that it quote it is possible to
establish a case for impeachment based
on a non criminal allegation of abuse of
power he also stated it is clear that
high crimes and misdemeanors can
encompass non criminal conduct more
recently professor Turley again the
Republican witness at our hearing
wrote an opinion piece in The Washington
Post entitled where the Trump defense
goes too far in this piece he stated
that the president's argument is as
politically unwise as it is
constitutionally short-sighted he added
if successful would also come at a
considerable cost for the Constitution
although I disagree with professor
Turley on many many issues here he is
clearly right and I might say the same
thing of then house manager Lindsey
Graham who in President Clinton's trial
flatly rejected the notion that
impeachable offenses are limited to
violations of established law here is
what he said plus a high crime
how about an important person hurt
somebody at low means it's not very
scholarly but I think it's a truth I
think that's what they meant by high
crimes doesn't even have to be a crime
it's just when you start using your
office and you're acting in a way that
hurts people
you've committed a higher crime there
are many reasons why high crimes and
misdemeanors are not and cannot be
limited to violations of the Criminal
Code we address them at Lenz
in the briefs we have filed and the
report of the House Judiciary Committee
respecting these articles of impeachment
but I would like to highlight a few
especially important considerations I'll
talk I'll tick through them quickly
first there is the matter of the
historical record the framers could not
have meant could not have meant to limit
impeachment to statutory crimes
presidents ought to be impeached and
removed from office for treason bribery
and other high crimes and misdemeanors
but bribery was not made a statutory
crime until 1837 second the president's
position is contradicted by the
Constitution's text the framers
repeatedly referred to crimes offenses
and punishment crimes offenses and
punishment elsewhere in the Constitution
but here they refer to high crimes that
matters it matters because the phrase
high crimes refers to offenses against
the state rather than to work a day
crimes and that matters because the
phrase high crimes and misdemeanors have
a rich history in England where where he
had been applied in many many cases that
did not involve crimes under British law
when the framers added high crimes here
here but nowhere else in the
Constitution they made a deliberate
choice any doubt on that score is
dispelled by the framers own statements
in Federalist number 65 Alexander
Hamilton explained that impeachable
offenses are defined fundamentally by
the abuse or violation of some public
trust a few years later James Wilson a
constitutional convention delegate
agreed with Hamilton Wilson stated
impeachments and defenses and defenders
impeachable come not within the sphere
of ordinary jurisprudence they are
founded on different principles are
governed by different Maxim's
and are directed to different objects
George Mason expressed concern that the
president might abuse the pardon power
to quote screen from punishment those
whom he had secretly instigated to
commit a crime and thereby prevent as
discovery of his own guilt sound
familiar
James Madison responded directly to
Mason's concern because Mason's concern
was that the pardon power might be too
broad the president might misuse his
broad pardon power to - to pardon his
own co-conspirators and prevent the
Discovery's own guilt may Madison
responded if the president be connected
in any suspicious manner with any person
and there be grounds to believe he will
shelter him the house of representatives
can impeach him they can remove him that
found guilty at the North Carolina
ratifying convention James Eyre doe who
would go on to serve on the Supreme
Court responded to the same concern he
is sure delegates that if the president
abused his power with quote some corrupt
motive or other he would be liable to
impeachment in the early 1800s this
understanding was echoed by Supreme
Court justice story who wrote his famous
treatise on the Constitution there he
rejected the equation of crimes and
impeachable offenses which he stated
must be examined upon very broad and
comprehensive principles of Public
Policy and duty later in American
history Chief Justice and former
president William Howard Taft as well as
chief justice Charles Evans Hughes
publicly stated that impeachable
offenses are not limited to crimes but
instead capture a broader range of
misconduct
indeed under Teague under Chief Justice
Taft
the Supreme Court unanimously observed
that abuse of the president's pardon
power to frustrate the enforcement of
court orders would suggest resort to
impeachment and this is squirt now
notice pardon power is unlimited what
they're saying here is abuse of the
pardon power use of the pardon power for
corrupt motive whose impeachable and if
all that Authority is not enough to
convince you there is more historians
have shown that American colonists
before the Revolution and American
States after the Revolution but before
1787 all impeached officials for non
criminal conduct over the past two
centuries moreover a strong majority of
the impeachment voted by the house have
included one or more allegations that
did not charge a violation of criminal
law indeed the Senate has convicted and
removed multiple judges on non criminal
grounds George Archibald was removed in
1912 for non criminal speculation in
coal properties judge Ritter was removed
in 1936 for the non criminal offense of
bringing his court into scandal and
disrepute during Judge Ritter's case one
of my predecessors as chairman of the
House Judiciary Committee stated
expressly we do not assume the
responsibility of proving that the
respondent is guilty of a crime as that
term is known to criminal jurisprudence
what is true for judges is also true for
presidents at least on this point the
House Judiciary Committee approved three
articles of impeachment against
President Nixon each of them encompassed
many acts that did not violate federal
law
one of the articles obstruction of
Congress involved no allegations of any
legal violation and that is worth
reflecting on why President Nixon was
forced to resign most Americans are
familiar with the story the House
Judiciary Committee approved articles of
impeachment in July 1974 those articles
passed with bipartisan support
although most Republicans stood by
President Nixon then the smoking tape
came out within a week almost everyone
who supported the president a week
or changed his position and the
president was forced to resign because
of what was revealed on the smoking gun
tape within a week senator Goldwater and
others from the Senate went to the
president and said you won't have a
single vote in the Senate you must
resign or you will be removed from
office because of the evidence and the
smoking gun tape but what was on the
smoking gun tape the smoking gun tape
were recordings of President Nixon
instructing White House officials to
pressure the CIA and the FBI to end the
Watergate investigation no law
explicitly prohibited that conversation
it was not in that sense a crime but
President Nixon had abused his power he
had tried to use to government agencies
the FBI in the CIA for his personal
benefit his impeachment and removal was
certain and he announced his resignation
within days decades later in President
Clinton's case the Judiciary Committee
reported on the articles of impeachment
stated the actions of President Clinton
do not have to rise to the level of
violating the federal statute regarding
obstruction of justice in order to
justify impeachment there is thus
overwhelming authority against
restricting impeachment stew violations
have established or statutory law every
relevant principle of constitutional law
compels that result
so does common sense impeachment is not
a punishment for crimes impeachment
exists to address threats to the
political system applies only to
political officials and responds not by
imprisonment to fines but only by
stripping political power it would make
no sense to say that a president who
engages in horrific abuses must be
allowed to remain in Congress in office
unless Congress had anticipated his or
her specific conduct in advance and
written a statute expressly outlawing it
for one thing that would be practically
impossible as just a story observed the
threats posed by presidential abuse are
of so various and complex a character
that it would be almost absurd
to attempt a comprehensive list the
Constitution is not a suicide pact it
does not leave a stuck with presidents
who abuse their power in unforeseen ways
that threaten our security and democracy
until recently it did not occur to me
that our president would call a foreign
leader and the man the Sham
investigation meant to kneecap his
political opponents all in exchange for
releasing vital military aid that the
president was already required by law to
provide no one anticipated that a
president would stoop to this misconduct
and Congress has passed no specific law
to make this behavior a crime yet this
is precisely the kind of abuse that the
framers had in mind when they wrote the
impeachment clause and when they charged
Congress with determining when the
president's conduct was so clearly wrong
so definitely beyond the pale so
threatening to the constitutional order
as to require his removal and that is
why we are here today you must judge for
yourselves where the justice will be had
for president Trump's crimes against our
freedom and the Constitution I will
conclude by highlighting a few points
that merits special emphasis as you
apply the law of impeachment to
president Trump's misconduct first
impeachment is not for petty offenses
the president's conduct must constitute
as Mason's put it a great and dangerous
offense against the nation offenses that
threaten the Constitution second
impeachable offenses involved wrongdoing
that reveal the president as a
continuing threat if he is allowed to
remain in office in other words we fully
recognize that impeachment does not
exist for a mistake it does not apply to
acts than a merely unwise or unpopular
impeachment is reserved for deliberate
decisions by the president to embark on
a course of conduct that betrays his
oath of office and does violence to the
Constitution when the president has
engaged in such conduct and when there
is strong evidence that he will do so
again when he has told us
so again when he has told us he's that
it's okay to invite interference from a
foreign power into our next election the
case for removal is at its peak this is
certainly the case when the invites
indeed attempts to compel a foreign
government to help him subvert the
integrity of our next election there can
be no greater threat to the Republic
finally high crimes and misdemeanors
involve conduct that is recognizably
wrong to a reasonable honorable citizen
the framers adopted a standard for
impeachment that could stand the test of
time at the same time the structure of
the Constitution implies that
impeachable offenses should not come as
a surprise impeachment is aimed at
presidents who act as if they are above
the law at presidents who believe their
own interests are more important than
those of the nation and thus at
presidents who ignore right and wrong in
pursuit of their own game abuse betrayal
corruption here are each of the core
offenses the framers feared most the
presidents abuse of power
his betrayal of the national interest
and his corruption of our elections
plainly qualify as great and dangerous
offenses President Trump has made clear
in word indeed that he will persist in
such conduct if he is not removed from
power he poses a continuing threat to
our nation to the integrity of our
elections to our democratic order he
must not remain in power one moment
longer
mr. chief justice
senators presidents counsel we will not
walk through the presence abuse of power
the corrupt object of his scheme his
three official acts carrying out his
scheme his attempted cover-up and
exposure and the harm to our nation in
continuing threat caused by his
misconduct let's start first with the
object of the president's scheme and
Senators we have today provided handouts
that you can follow along in our slides
so as this first light indicates in this
portion of our presentation we will
discuss the evidence that shows
overwhelmingly that President Trump
directed this scheme with corrupt intent
with one corrupt objective to obtain
foreign assistance in his reelection bid
in the 2020 United States presidential
election we will walk through first how
the president wanted Ukraine to help in
his reelection campaign he wanted
Ukraine to publicly announce two
investigations one into his political
rival Joe Biden and the second into the
debunked conspiracy theory related to
Ukraine interference in the 2016
election President Trump himself later
confirmed this intent in public
statements we will then explain how we
know these investigations were solely
for presidents Trump's personal
political gain first president Trump
made clear he cared only about the
announcement the announcement of the
investigations not the actual
investigations
second president Trump similarly made
clear he cared only about the big stuff
the big stuff meaning his political
investigations third he used his
personal attorney mr. Giuliani who
repeatedly told us he was pursuing the
investigations in his capacity as the
president's personal lawyer and that
this wasn't about foreign policy fourth
and fifth there is no real dispute that
these investigations were never part of
an official US policy and they in fact
went outside official channels the
Department of Justice even publicly
confirmed that they were never asked to
talk to Ukraine about these
investigations never six multiple
officials who knew what was going on
repeatedly reported these concerns to
supervisors and even the NSC legal
advisors 7th Ukraine expressed concerns
multiple times that these were political
investigations and Ukraine didn't want
to get involved in domestic US politics
eighth the White House tried to bury the
call 9th President Trump himself told us
he really wanted and cared about in his
own words in many public statements and
finally despite the president counsels
attempts to justify his actions the
evidence makes clear that President
Trump did not care about anti-corruption
efforts in Ukraine this was only about
one thing his political investigations
we are following along of the slight now
as I mentioned the object of the
present scheme is clear two
investigations to help his political
pre-election the Constitution grants the
president broad authority to conduct
u.s. foreign policy he is our commander
in chief and chief diplomat when the
president of the United States calls a
foreign leader a president's first and
only objective should be to get foreign
leaders to do what is in the best
board's best for the u.s. national
interest consistent with the faithful
execution of his oath of office and
consistent with official US policy but
on July 25 when President Trump called
the president of Ukraine president drop
Trump did the opposite instead of
following official u.s. talking points
instead of listening to his staff on
what was important to our national
interests President Trump as Ukraine for
something that benefit only himself his
political investigations and not only
did these investigations diverge from
u.s. national interests as you're here
president Trump's actions harmed our
national security it put in himself
above our country he put our country at
risk and that is why his actions are so
dangerous now let's take a moment it
looked carefully at the two
investigations that President Trump
sought from Ukraine which are at the
heart of the president's scheme and how
he stood to benefit politically from
Ukraine's announcement of each as you
can see on the slide the first
investigation was of course a former
Vice President Biden let's go straight
to that July 25 telephone call again
where President Trump stated clearly
each of these investigations he wanted
so let's start with Vice President Joe
Biden and his in the removal of corrupt
prosecutor in the Ukraine the first
invitation investigation related to
former Vice President Joe Biden in the
Ukrainian gas company verismo Holdings
and whose board his son hunter Biden
used to sit President Trump himself
summarized the theory behind his request
in broad strokes and his July 25 call
with President Solinsky here's what he
said the other thing there's a lot of
talk about biting some that Biden
stopped the prosecution and a lot of
people want to find out about that so
that whatever you can do with the
Attorney General would be great
Biden went around bragging that he
stopped their prosecution so if you can
look into that it sounds horrible to me
now let's look carefully at the
investigation president Trump was asking
for and what it was based on in short
President Trump asked for the
investigation into Biden based on a
made-up theory that no one agreed with
no one will go into this in more detail
but at a high level the allegation is
that late in 2015
Biden pressured Ukraine to remove the
then prosecutor general Viktor shokhin
by threatening to withhold approximately
1 billion in loan guarantees if he was
not removed according to this theory
Vice President Biden did this in order
to help his son in a company called
verismo Vice President Biden's son sat
on the board of ERISA as if there he
goes Vice President Biden tried to
remove Ukraine's prosecutor
all to make sure the prosecutor wouldn't
investigate that that specific company
Marissa
because again his son was on the board
then senators if that doesn't sound
far-fetched and complicate it to you it
should so let's take this step by step
and start from the beginning in 2014
Vice President Biden's son Hunter joined
the board of the Ukrainian natural gas
former yzma Holdings at the time were
Isthmus owner a ukrainian oligarch and
former government minister was under
investigation in 2015
viktor Shokan became ukraine's
prosecutor general a job similar to
Attorney General in the United States
although Shokan vowed to keep
investigating verismo amid an
international push to root out
corruption in Ukraine he allowed the
verismo investigation to go dormant
allowed it to go dormant that is when he
was removed he was not actively
investigating verismo Piatt let it go
dormant
moreover Shogun was widely perceived as
ineffective and corrupt George Kent the
second most senior official at the US
Embassy in Kiev at the time described
Shokan s quote atypical Ukraine
prosecutor who lived a lifestyle
far in excess of his government salary
who never prosecuted anybody known for
having committed a crime and covered up
crimes that were known to have been
committed in late 2015
Vice President Biden who had assumed a
significant role in US policy toward
Ukraine publicly called for the removal
of mr. Shokan because of his failure his
failure to adequately combat corruption
but Vice President Biden wasn't alone
the European Union our European allies
the International Monetary Fund
reformers inside Ukraine also wanted mr.
shokhin removed to reform the Ukrainian
prosecutor general's office to reform it
reforming the prosecutor general's
office was also supported on a
bipartisan basis by the Ukrainian caucus
here in the Senate On February 12 2016
after Vice President Biden had urged for
the removal of mr. Shokan but before
they weaken Ukrainian Parliament voted
to remove him a bipartisan group of
senators including Senators Portman
Durbin Shaheen Ron Johnson Murphy Kirk
Blumenthal and sherrod Brown sent a
letter to president poroshenko that
urged him to make urgent reforms to the
prosecutor general's office the month
after the senator sent that letter mr.
Shokan was fired he was fired so let's
be very very clear Vice President Biden
called for the removal of this
prosecutor at the official direction of
US policy because the prosecutor was
widely perceived as corrupt and with the
support of all our international allies
his actions were therefore supported by
the executive branch Congress and the
international community common sense
would tell us that this allegation
against Joe Biden
is false and that there was no
legitimate basis for any investigation
but there are several other reasons you
know that the only reason President
Trump won at Ukraine to announce the
investigation into Biden that was also
solely for this very own personal
benefit so if you look at the site
it'll summer right some points first
none of the 17 witnesses in the houses
inquiry said there was any factual basis
for this allegation not one of the 17 to
the contrary they testified it was false
second as I mentioned the former
prosecutor general Vice President
General Vice President Biden was widely
we considered to be corrupt and failed
to investigate corruption in Ukraine
thus removing him from office would only
increase the chances that BER yzma would
be investigated for possible corruption
third because the prosecutor was so
corrupt Vice President Biden calling for
his removal was also at the direction of
official US policy and undertaken with a
unanimous support of our allies fourth
the successor to the fired Ukrainian
prosecutor general admitted that Vice
President Biden's son didn't do anything
wrong in connection with BER yzma so the
entire premise of the investigation that
the president wanted Ukraine to pursue
was simply false finally President Trump
didn't care about any of this until 2019
but with Vice President Biden became the
frontrunner for the Democratic
presidential nomination and polls showed
that he had the largest head-to-head
lead against President Trump that became
a problem
let's start with the first and second
points Vice President Biden's conduct
was uniformly validated by the witnesses
in the house
investigation who confirmed his conduct
was consistent with US policy every
single witness who was asked about the
allegations again said that Biden had
nothing to do with it and it was false
they testified that he acted properly
every witness with knowledge of this
issue testified that Vice President
Biden was carrying out official US
policy in calling for Shogun's removal
shokhin was corrupt and this witness
explained the u.s. was not alone in this
view all of our European allies also
supported this action
there is simply no evidence nothing nada
in their record to support this baseless
allegation I'd like to go through some
of that testimony now first here dr.
hill and mr. Holmes so let's watch now
are either dr. hill are you aware of any
evidence to support the allegations
against Vice President Biden I'm not no
and in fact mr. Holmes the former
prosecutor general of Ukraine who Vice
President Biden encouraged to fire was
actually corrupt is that right correct
and was not pursuing corruption
investigations and prosecutions right my
understanding is the prosecution all the
time Shokan was not at that time
pursuing investigations of barrese MO or
the Biden's and in fact removing that
corrupt prosecutor general was part of
the United States anti-corruption policy
isn't that correct that's correct and
not just us but all of our allies and
other institutions are involved in
Ukraine at the time
and bastard Jovanovic to confirm this
points let's watch her testify and in
fact when Vice President Biden acted to
remove the former corrupt prosecutor in
Ukraine did he do so as part of official
United States policy official US policy
I was endorsed and was the policy of a
number of other international
stakeholders other countries other
monetary institutions financial
institutions and similarly when asked if
there was any factual basis to support
the allegations about Biden George Kent
replied none whatsoever
lieutenant-colonel vid Minh and Miss
Williams also confirmed that they are
not aware of any credible evidence to
support the notion that Vice President
Biden did anything wrong an ambassador
Volcker testified that the by nations
were not credible and that Biden quote
respects his duties of higher office now
as I mentioned there was also concrete
reason that the u.s. government wanted
Shokan removed as David Holmes a senior
official at the US Embassy in Ukraine
testified by the time that Shokan was
finally removed in 2016 there was there
were strong concerns that Shogun himself
corrupt was corrupt and not
investigating potential corruption in
the country in fact part of the concern
was that shokhin was not investigating
verismo under Shogun the investigation
into the owner of verismo
for earlier conduct had stalled and was
dormant that was part of the reason why
the United States and other countries
wanted to remove shokhin because of this
and has confirmed by witness testimony
we will hear shortly calling for
Sjogren's replacement would actually
increase the chances that bruceman would
be in
in other words Shokan was corrupt and
not investigating allegations against
purissima so what Vice President Biden
was calling for so what choke ins
removal in advocating for his
replacement it would actually increase
chances a burr is MMus investigation
ambassador yogic George ivanovitch made
this point during her testimony let's
listen and in fact if he were helped to
remove a corrupt Ukrainian prosecutor
general who was not prosecuting enough
corruption that would increase the
chances that corrupt companies in
Ukraine would be investigated isn't that
right one would think so and that could
include bery smih right yes
president Trump and his allies have
tried to justify president Trump's
withholding a military eight and a White
House meeting unless Ukraine announced
the investigations he wanted by saying
it's the same thing vice president did
when he called for Ukraine to remove its
corrupt prosecutor it is not the same
thing as you've just heard Vice
President Biden followed official US
policy he went through official channels
to remove the prosecutor that was
corrupt and he did it with the support
of our allies that is the exact opposite
of what President Trump did he pushed
Ukraine for an investigation that has no
basis that no one agreed with that was
not at all US policy and that only
benefited him George can't address this
very point during his testimony let's
listen and mr. Kent and mr. Taylor
the defenders of the president's
behavior have made a big deal out of the
fact that
President Biden encouraged the
Ukrainians to remove a corrupt former
Ukrainian prosecutor 2016 mister Shokan
in fact Senator Rand Paul on Sunday said
and I quote him their impeaching the
president President Trump for exactly
the same thing that Joe Biden did is
that correct
is what the president what the president
did in his phone call and what Joe Biden
did in terms of mister shokhin are those
exactly the same things and if not how
are they different I do not think they
are the same things what former Vice
President Biden requested of former
president of Ukraine poroshenko was the
removal of a corrupt prosecutor general
viktor Shokan who had undermined a
program of assistance that we had spent
again US taxpayer money to try to build
an independent investigator unit to go
after corrupt prosecutors and there was
a case called the diamond prosecutor
case in which Shokan destroyed the
entire ecosystem that we were trying to
help create the investigators the judges
who issued the warrants the law
enforcement that had warrants to do the
wiretapping everybody to protect his
former driver whom he'd made a
prosecutor that's what Joe Biden was
asking removed the corrupt prosecutor so
Joe Joe Biden was participating in an
open effort established
whole-of-government effort to address
corruption in Ukraine that is correct
great so mr. Kenton as you look at this
whole mess Rudy Giuliani President Trump
in your opinion was this a comprehensive
and whole of government effort to end
corruption in Ukraine referring to the
requests in July exactly I would not say
so no sir
in short the allegations against vice
president by Biden are groundless and so
there is no comparison
none at all between what he did and the
president's Trump's abuse of power now
let's turn to the third point part of
the allegation against former Vice
President Biden is that he pushed for
the corrupt Ukrainian prosecutors
removal in order to protect his son from
the investigation in fact the
president's claim about being concerned
about corruption in Ukraine has recently
emphasized this component of the theory
that the president wanted Ukraine to
investigate hunter Biden's work on the
board of verismo not the former vice
president this too is false simply false
you need look look no further than the
July 25 call and the president's own
statements to see that the president
wanted the Ukrainians to investigate
Vice President Biden let's look again at
what the president's call said quote the
other thing there's a lot of talk about
Biden son that Biden stopped the
prosecution and a lot of people wanted
to fight about find out about that
whatever you can do with the Attorney
General it would be great
Biden went around bragging that he
stopped the prosecution so you can look
into it it sounds horrible to me the
president was clearly asking president
Solinsky to investigate Joe Biden and
what did the president say on the White
House lawn on October 3rd when he was
asked about you the Ukraine scheme he
said quote well I think they should if
they were honest about it you saw the
film yesterday they would start a major
investigation into the Biden's it's a
very simple answer he said the Biden's
plural not one Biden the Biden's it's
clear that the president wanted for what
he wanted from Ukraine an investigation
to smear his political rival but even if
the president wanted an investigation of
hunter Biden there is no basis for that
either now how do you know
well Ukraine's former prosecutor general
admitted that the allegation against
Vice President Biden's son was plainly
false you can see it on the slide his
own words plainly false then Ukrainian
prosecutor general Yuri lysenko recanted
his earlier allegations and confirmed
quote Biden was definitely not involved
in any wrongdoing involving BER yzma so
even the Ukrainians believe that Biden's
son did nothing wrong the long and short
of it is that there was no basis for the
investigation that the president was
pursuing and pushing none he was doing
it only for his own political benefit
but let's look at one more important
reason why it's clear that President
Trump simply wanted a political benefit
from Ukraine's announcement of this
investigation and didn't care about the
underlying conduct the allegations
against Vice President Biden were based
on events that occurred in late 2015 and
early 2016
they're all well publicized at the time
but as soon as President Trump took
office he increased knowledge
Carrie support to Ukraine in 2017 and
the next year 2018 but it wasn't until
2019 over three years after Vice
President Biden called for Shogun's
removal three years after that president
Trump started pushing Ukraine to
investigate that conduct so what changed
what changed
why did President Trump not care at all
about Biden's request on the removal of
cocaine the year after it happened in
2017 or the next year in 2018 senators
you know what changed in 2019 when
President Trump suddenly cared
it's that Biden got in the race April 25
Vice President Biden announced he would
run for president in 2020 if President
Trump were so concerned about this
alleged conception why didn't he push
Ukraine to investigate when he entered
office in 2017 or in 2018
after Biden gave public remarks about
how he pressured Ukraine to remove
Shogun why did President Trump instead
wait until former Vice President Biden
was campaigning for the Democratic
nomination senator senators it's obvious
because President Trump wanted to hurt
Vice President Biden's candidacy and
help himself politically he pushed for
an investigation in 2019 because that's
when it would be valuable to him
president Trump he pushed for it when it
started to become clear that Vice
President Biden could beat him and he
had good reason to be concerned let's
look at the slide about some polls
throughout the scheme polling had
consistently shown the former
vice-president handily beating vice
president President Trump by significant
margins in head-to-head matchups the
chart on the screen shows a Fox News
polls emphasizing this point the chart
shows that from March through December
Vice President Biden had consistently
led President Trump in national polls by
significant margins so beginning around
March Vice President Biden is meeting
the president in polls even on Fox News
in April Biden officially announces his
candidacy and then when the press that
is when the president gets worried in
May the president's personal lawyer
tells the press that he's planning to
travel to Ukraine to urge newly elected
president Solinsky to conduct the two
investigations one into Vice President
Biden
you know what else happened in May a Fox
News poll showed Biden beating Trump by
11 points this clearly did not go
unnoticed on May 9 the president's
personal lawyer mr. Giuliani said in an
interview and this is a quote I
guarantee you Joe Biden will not get to
Election Day without this being
investigated and by July right before
President Trump's call with President
Solinsky where he asked for the
investigation into the - Biden the Fox
News poll showed Biden beating Trump by
10 points and then on July 25th after
years of not caring what what vice
president did does President Trump ask
for an investigation in his formidable
political rival
in the 2020 election senators looking at
this timeline of events it is not
difficult to see why the investigation
of the Biden's
would be helpful to President Trump the
mere announcement of such an
investigation would admittedly tarnish
the former vice president's reputation
by embroiling him and his son in a
foreign criminal investigation even if
the charges were never pursued just the
mere announcement and if a foreign
country announced a formal investigation
into those allegations
it would give allegations against the
Biden's an air of call it credibility
and could carry through the election the
evidence is clear everyone knew even
Ukraine that there was no merit to the
allegation that Biden called for the
removal ashokan for any illegitimate
reason Biden asked for it because it was
consistent consistent with US policy
because Shogun was corrupt and with the
backing of our allies even President
Trump knew there was no basis for this
investigation that is why four years
after shoka's removal he continued to
support Ukraine never once raised the
issue
it wasn't until Biden began beating him
in the polls that he called for the
investigation the president asked
Ukraine for this investigation for one
reason and one reason only because he
knew he would it would be damaging to an
opponent who was consistently beating
him in the polls and therefore it could
help him get reelected in 2020 pesterin
Trump had the motive he had the
opportunity
and the means to commit this abuse of
power now let's turn to the second
investigation that present trouble on it
what do you want it is a widely debunked
conspiracy theory that Ukraine rather
than Russia interfered in the 2016 US
election to benefit president Trump's
opponent as we will explain the
allegation that Ukraine interfered in
the 2016 elections just like the elect
the allegation that Biden probably
removed the Ukraine prosecutor has
absolutely no basis in fact in fact this
theory ignored the unanimous conclusions
of the u.s. intelligence agency the
congressional intelligence committees
and special councilor Muller which found
that Russia Russia attacked our
elections it also went against the
Senate Intelligence Committee report
which found no evidence supporting that
Ukraine attacked our elections nor did
any witness support the theory that
Ukraine attacked our elections indeed
even president Trump's own advisors told
him that claim was false in fact the one
person who told president Trump his
theory is true who was it you know it
was our adversary Russia who had
everything to gain by deflecting the
blame from their attack on Ukraine let's
look at what President Trump was
actually suggesting Ukraine investigate
the theory is this instead of listening
to our entire intelligence community
that concluded that Russia interfered in
our 2016 election to assist Donald Trump
the new theory says it was Ukraine that
interfered in the election to help
Hillary Clinton and hurt Donald
Trump one aspect of this conspiracy
theory was that the American
cybersecurity firm CrowdStrike which had
helped the DNC respond to Russia's
cyberattack in 2016
moved a DNC server to Ukraine to prevent
the FBI from examining here's what
President Trump said about this
conspiracy theory during the 25 July 25
call quote I would like you to find out
what happened with this whole situation
with Ukraine they say CrowdStrike I
guess you have one of your wealthy
people the server they say Ukraine has
it once again if this sounds far-fetched
and crazy it should because it is there
is simply no factual basis to support
this conspiracy theory let's walk
through the concrete reasons why first
as I mentioned our entire US
intelligence community the Senate Select
Committee on Intelligence and special
counsel mother all unanimously found
that Russia not Ukraine interfered in
the 2016 elections and Russia did it to
help Donald Trump and hurt Hillary
Clinton here's an example of that this
is a conclusion of the Director of
National Intelligence report entitled
assessing Russian activities and
intentions in recent US elections I'll
quote a bit part in it you can follow on
a slide we assess Russian President
Vladimir Putin's ordered an influence
campaign in 2016 aimed at the u.s.
presidential election Russia's goals
were to undermine public faith in the US
democratic process denigrates
Thierry Clinton and harm her
electability and potential presidency we
further assess Putin in the Russian
government developed a clear preference
for president elect Trump we have high
confidence in these judgments end quote
clear president for president elect
Trump and here's a conclusion of the
Senate Select Committee on Intelligence
quote the committee found that the
Russia based internet research agency
sought to influence the 2016 US
presidential election by harming Hillary
Clinton's chances of success in
supporting Donald Trump at the direction
of the Kremlin the committee found that
the Russian government tests and
supported the IRAs
interference in the 2016 US elections in
quote supporting Donald Trump at the
direction of the Kremlin that's what it
said and here's the special council's
conclusion Muller report in 2019 quote
as set forth in detailed in this report
the special counsels investigation
established that Russia interfering
interfered interfered in the 2016
presidential election principally
through operations first a Russia entity
carried out a social media campaign that
favored president candidate presidential
candidate Donald J Trump and disparage
presidential candidate Hillary Clinton
second a Russian intelligence service
conducted computer intrusion operations
against entities employees and
volunteers working on the Clinton
campaign and then released
stolen documents
on December 9 2019 even president
Trump's own FBI director Christopher Rea
stated unequivocally that there is no
evidence to support the theory that
Ukraine interfered in our election in
2016
here's a video of that interview let's
watch it's all those did the government
of Ukraine directly interfere in the
2016 election on the scale that the
Russians did we have no information that
indicates the Ukraine interfered with
the 2016 presidential election when you
see politicians pushing this notion are
you concerned about that in terms of its
impact on the American public well look
there's all kinds of people saying all
kinds of things out there I think it's
important for the American people to be
thoughtful consumers of information to
think about the sources of it and to
think about the support and predication
for what they hear and I think part of
us being well protected against maligned
foreign influence is to build together
an American public that's resilient that
has appropriate media literacy and that
takes its information with a grain of
salt and Putin has been pushing this
theory and your message to him and in
terms of the American public
stop trying to interfere with our
elections we recently heard from
President himself that he wanted the
CrowdStrike portion of this whole
conspiracy in the Ukraine investigated
and I and I'm hearing you say there's no
evidence to support that as far as you
know as I said we have no we at the FBI
have no information that would indicate
that Ukraine tried to interfere in the
2016 presidential election
[Music]
you heard him he said no information
that it would indicate that Ukraine
tried to interfere in the 2016
presidential election so to be really
really clear there is no real dispute
that Russia not Ukraine attacked our
elections but it's not just that there
is no evidence to support this
conspiracy theory it's more dangerous
than that because where did this theory
come from you guessed it the Russians
Russia Russian President Vladimir Putin
and Russian intelligence services
perpetuated this false debunked
conspiracy theory now remember there is
no dispute among the telogen skom unity
the Russia's that a Russia attacked our
2016 election the Senate's own
Intelligence Committee published a
report telling us that as well so it's
no surprise that Russia wants to blame
somebody else in fact President Trump
even said that President Putin is the
one who told him it was Ukraine who you
interfered in our elections in short
this theory that the Russians are
promoting to interfere yet again in our
democratic process and deflect blame
from their own attacks against us but
what is so dangerous is that President
Trump is helping them perpetuate this
our own president it's helping our
adversary attack our processes and to
help his own reelection
dr. hill an expert on these matters
explains it in more detail as to why
this is very concerning let's watch this
relates the second thing I want to
communicate
based on questions and statements I've
heard some of you on this committee
appear to believe that Russia and its
security services did not conduct a
campaign against our country and that
perhaps somehow for some reason Ukraine
did this is a fictional narrative that
has been perpetrated and propagated by
the Russian security services themselves
the unfortunate truth is that Russia was
the foreign power that systematically
attacked our democratic institutions in
2016 this is the public conclusion of
our intelligence agencies confirmed in
bipartisan congressional reports it is
beyond dispute even if some of the
underlying details must remain
classified
the impacts of the successful 2016
Russian campaign remains evident today
our nation is being torn apart truth is
questioned our highly professional
expert career foreign service is being
undermined u.s. support for Ukraine
which continues to face armed aggression
aggression has been politicized the
Russian government's goal is to weaken
our country to diminish America's global
role and to neutralize a perceived u.s.
threat to Russian interests
their goal is to weaken our country to
diminish America's global role and to
neutralize a perceived u.s. threat to
Russian interests that's why it's so
dangerous because despite the lack of
any evidence to support this debunked
conspiracy theory
the unanimous conclusion of the
intelligence community Congress special
counsel Miller and the FBI to the
contrary President Trump continued to
promote this fake conspiracy theory just
because it would be beneficial and
helpful to his own reelection campaign
even President Trump's own senior
advisors told him this allegations were
false
Tom Bussard president Trump's former
homeland security adviser stated
publicly that the CrowdStrike theory had
been debunked here's that interview
let's watch it's not only a conspiracy
theory it is completely debunked you
know I don't want to be glib about this
matter but last year a retired former
senator Judd Gregg wrote a piece in the
hill magazine saying the three ways or
the five ways to impeach oneself and the
third way was to hire Rudy Giuliani
and at this point I am deeply frustrated
with what he and the legal team is doing
and repeating that debunked theory to
the president it sticks in his mind when
he hears it over and over again and for
clarity here George let me just again
repeat that it has no validity the
United States government reached its
conclusion on attributing to Russia the
DNC hack in 2016 before it even
communicated it to the FBI and long
before the FBI ever knocked on the door
at the DNC so a server inside the DNC
was not relevant to our determination to
the attribution it was made up front and
beforehand and so while servers can be
important in some of the investigations
that followed it has nothing to do
with the US government's attribution of
Russia for the dnc hacking the theory
has no validity that's what he said dr.
hill too testified that White House
officials including mr. Buzzard in
former national security adviser HR
McMaster spend a lot of time refuting
the CrowdStrike conspiracy theory to
president Trump let's hear it now
dr. hill is this a reference to this
debunked conspiracy theory about ukraine
interference in the 2016 election that
you discussed at the open your opening
statement as well as with chairmanship
their reference to crop psych in the
survey yes that's correct
and it is your understanding that there
is is no basis for these allegations is
that correct that's correct now isn't it
also true that some of president Trump's
most senior advisors had informed him
that this theory of Ukraine interference
in the 2016 election was false that's
correct
when she was asked is it false she said
that's correct
if Baldomir put his goals as test as dr.
hill testified work to deflect from
russia's systemic interference in our
election and to drive a wedge between
the United States and Ukraine he has
succeeded beyond his wildest dreams
the alternative narrative of Ukrainian
interference of the 2016 election has
now been picked up by the president's
defenders and the conservative media it
has muddled the waters regarding
Russia's own interference in our
elections efforts that remain ongoing as
we have learned last week this week from
reporting that Russia hacked verismo if
there were any doubt about how President
Putin feels about the president's
conduct you need only look to Putin's
own words his statement of November 20
tells it all quote thank God nobody is
accusing us anymore of interfering in US
elections now they're accusing Ukraine
that's a short quotation from Putin but
it speaks volumes even though President
Trump knew that there was no factual
basis for the theory that it was Ukraine
that interfered in the 2016 election
rather than Russia and you that Russia
was perpetuating this theory he still
wanted president szalinski to pursue the
investigation why because while Putin
and Russia clearly stood by to gain by
promoting this conspiracy theory about
Ukraine so did Donald Trump he knew it
would be politically helpful to his
2010-2020 election
an announcement of an investigation by
Ukraine where they breathe new life into
a debunked conspiracy theory that
Ukrainian election interference was but
there in 2016 and it landed great
credibility it would have cast doubt on
the conclusions of the Intelligence
Committee and Special Counsel Miller
that Russia interfered in the 2016
election to help President Trump and it
would have helped eliminate a perceived
threat to the legitimacy of Donald
Trump's presidency that he was only
elected because of the help he received
from President Putin I now yield to mr.
Schiff the majority leader is recognized
man that we take a 15-minute break at
this point without objection so ordered
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
madam-ji da the nerves things of idiot
and Antonia
we want to make every day - horrible for
the people that need it we make every
day happy for the people around us but
not for tomorrow to be good because we
don't know what's happening to work
my name is Mahmoud Jin D 19 years old
now and I'm originally from Syria I was
born and raised in Syria and as you all
know in 2011 sea revolution sparked and
after a while it developed into a civil
war and because of that we had to flee
the country because my mom got arrested
twice and then we received death threats
well originally I didn't really
understand what was going on and I've
always had a dream to travel so for some
reason I was more excited but then I
realized that we were fleeing and not
were forcibly displaced from Syria and
it wasn't just trapped in Lebanon
because of the government regulations
and for a lot of reasons I couldn't go
to school for almost three years
actually but however after half a year
of my arrival in Lebanon I started to
give classes in refugee camps small
classes gathered to learn runway and
give them teach them of photography and
English and after a while the small
project developed into a real school and
since we've started until now we